justin here with a gamespot news update
Xbox boss Phil Spencer has said that the
PlayStation 4 has a huge lead and he's
not sure if the xbox is going to be able
to catch up Spencer's candid comments
came during a panel the 2015 geekwire
summit as reported by videogamer.com
when Spencer was asked if he thought the
xbox one could outsell the ps4 this
generation he replied you know I don't
know you know the length of the
generation they Sony have a huge lead
and they have a good product the head of
Xbox went on to say that the situation
surrounding the xbox one's launch marked
by dramatic policy reversals and
controversial comments from executives
who have since left the company had a
negative effect on the platform's
ability to have a strong start in fact
Spencer admitted that Microsoft
fundamentally lost the trust of our most
loyal customers at that time whether
it's always on used games whatever the
feature was we lost trust in them that
they were at the center of our
decision-making process he said we'll be
building a product for us or were we
building a product for the gamers and as
soon as that question came into people's
minds and they looked at anything
whether it was the power of our box our
launch lineup microtransactions any of
the features that you talked about what
you find is very quickly you'll lose the
benefit of the doubt in 2014 Spencer was
promoted to head of Xbox and since then
he's been reversing previous policies
and trying to regain the trust of fans
and consumers right now Spencer is more
concerned with getting the xbox one into
as many people's hands as possible
rather than beating the playstation 4
back in September sony announced that
the playstation 4 had sold over 25
million units worldwide while
Microsoft's last number puts the xbox at
around 10 million units for even more
news stay tuned to gamespot
you